questions from amber and Tyler and is
about trying to catch up so he feels
rushed 29 years old married but feeling
behind on the goals you know trying to
pay the bills as well as reach that new
level of success but it's feeling like
is always playing catch-up and hasn't
gotten where he wants to go yet and
wants to kind of rush his way to success
yeah and manage is scheduled to do that
so what what advice would you have for
them for me it's all about visualizing
the angle right so I think it's really
difficult to achieve your goal if you
haven't defined it you know so to find
that goal um and at first it's going to
be like really big and broad you know so
if your goal is to start a business and
you have a loose concept for that
business um that's a really big broad
you know and if that's all you have I
don't want to say it's unattainable but
it's really difficult to attain that
goal so taking that big concept and then
start chunking out into smaller
milestones and then taking those
milestones and then starting to chunk
those out into actual tasks that are
going to get any closer and closer to
that goal so I'm really passionate about
fiction and I'm a writer so I've never
written a book I've never written a
piece of fiction uh but just this past
year I started writing my first book but
I work full-time as a project manager I
have a wife I have a son really
difficult for me to just like drop
things and work on this book um but I
had my end goal of mine and i chunked it
out into the chapters and then from the
jackers i chunked it out into the
smaller outlines and then I I blocked
out time on my schedule each day to hit
a work account so i had a tangible goal
i want to write you know a thousand
words a day um or 750 words a day and
then I really woke up in the morning
with that drive I looked at my goal
which I have on posted though which is
sitting right by my bed um you know and
I woke up with that passion in that
drive and I reminded myself how much I
wanted it and then I sat down and I just
started doing
I started writing words and maybe
they're not that great and I'll edit
them later but just the fact that like
you just have to start doing you know
you can talk talk talk at the end of the
day just visualize your goal chunk it
out into you know actual tasks set
metrics to to show that you're making
progress and then just that's cool I'm
looking forward to seeing the book too
man that's exciting I'm excited one of
my favorite bits of advice is from
Michael Dell who talked about
understanding your point of leverage and
one of the things that I constantly try
to think about for myself is what's the
best use of my time to drive the needle
as far as i can forward so you know even
a task is of 100 things plus you're
behind you know you feel in your life
and you catch up on your bills and wants
for town with your your wife there's a
lot of things on your plate so you only
have a certain amount of time to be able
to focus on this new thing what activity
or you great at that you can really
spend energy on that's really going to
move it forward so yes you have your
goals you have your vision you have your
plan and then look at that task list and
which one that if you attack today
that's going to help really move your
project forward because it's leveraging
what you're passionate about what you've
got you know your break skills at I feel
like if people understood their point of
leverage a lot better than you be able
to make faster growth and catch up and
get to where you want to go a lot sooner